karim un déchet tab au losc au
professeur invité à l'université d'état
de moscou
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors alexeï navalni martyrs ou
bien ton style de faire oublier ces
poursuites qui pèsent sur lui
bonsoir difficile quand même pour jeu
pour lui de jouer les martyrs ce n'est
pas vraiment le retour de soljenitsyne
que nous sommes en train de voir sur les
vidéos qui sont diffusées quelques
centaines de personnes
dans l'ensemble qui l'attendent avoue
que dans l'ensemble ils sont quand même
ses partisans donc sont des gens qui
travaillent pour lui sont les gens qui
sont payés pour ça donc on peut pas
parler d'un soutien populaire massif
envers ce que l'occident s'acharne a
appelé l'opposant numéro un
concrètement il faut quand même pas
oublier que 1 à vali n'a pas été
condamné pour ses prises de position
politiques
il a été condamné pour des malversations
pour de l'escroquerie que son frère lui
en revanche qu'ils n'étaient pas aussi
médiatisée a réellement exécuté sa peine
de prison à la différence des avec séné
valley qui a parfaitement bénéficier de
de sa réputation médiatique et ça n'a
pas seulement pas du tout dérangé
lorsque il lui a été demandé à alors
qu'il était en allemagne de commencer à
recommencer à se présenter et à indiquer
son lieu de résidence sur ce qu'ils
découlaient de sa condamnation pénale de
il a manifestement joué sur le fait qu'
étant en allemagne en plus étant partis
légalement avec l'accord des autorités
publiques russes
il était plus soumis à rien c'est une
erreur il est sorti quand même de
l'hôpital sans route ça en septembre
pendant après
les choses normales reviennent s'il est
suffisamment en état pour donner des
conférences de presse
un peu partout il était suffisamment en
état pour rentrer en russie et reprendre
le cours normal de sa condamnation
pourquoi avoir mis en scène son retour
quelles sont ses intentions alors que la
justice russe l'a averti qu'il risquait
de se faire arrêter à son arrivée mais
c'est peut-être justement parce que la
justice russe la mise au pied du mur que
finalement il s'est décidé à rentrer
rappelons quand même que temps que la
justice russe n'a pas menacé de
transformer sa liberté conditionnelle en
condamnation réel à part des grandes
déclarations disant que si si bien sûr
il allait rentrer en russie pour mener
son combat il était beaucoup mieux au
chaud en allemagne or il semblerait que
l'allemagne elle commence à trouver
l'opposant numéro 1 entre guillemets un
petit peu lourd quand même à assumer
politiquement donc le dossier de navalni
a été transmis à la russie ce qui est
intéressant c'est que cavani s'est
opposé à la transmission dont son
dossier médical ce qui est assez
surprenant si en fait il était
soi-disant empoisonné en hobbit choc
pour né pas transmettez dossier médical
justement est ce sont quand même des
officiers allemands qui peut être pour
des raisons sécurité pour moi comme
c'est l'été sion qui prennent l'avion
qui ont fait son enregistrement à lui et
à sa part mme à l'aéroport de berne
donc on peut dire en quelque sorte que
l'allemagne a refilé la patate chaude en
disant bien que de toute façon elle
estime que c'est à la russie de devoir
mener l enquête
il est donc présenté alexeï navalni
comme l'opposant un majeur à vladimir
poutine vous dit l'opposant numéro un
qu'est ce qu'il pèse réellement dans le
paysage politique russe à 2% à peu près
selon en tout cas les les sondages donc
non il n'a strictement aucun poids
intérieur politique si c'est l'opposant
numéro 1 celle opposant demeurant
effectivement dans la presse mainstream
et dans les chancelleries occidentales
et nous sommes un peu si vous voulez sur
le même mode de ce que l'on a vu
au venezuela la nascar en en biélorussie
ce sont des personnes qui n'ont aucun
poids politique à l'intérieur qui sont
montés en aiguille parfaitement finances
est pris en main avec des équipes de
communication parfaitement financer
aussi autour d'eux et qu'ils jouent le
jeu de l'occident ce sont des personnes
qui sont absolument impossible à élire
faute des lectorats objectivement ce qui
permet de continuer à maintenir le
discours de ses opposants qui sont
réprimées dans leur pays la gestion du
cas quelle vanité dit sensible pour le
crémant c'est parfois présenté ainsi par
certains commentateurs quel est votre
regard
c'est un cas qui est sensible à à force
de traîner le problème c'est que le
kremlin prend semble prendre en super un
petit peu trop de pincettes avec navalni
parce qu'avec toutes les manifestations
illégales qu'il a organisé avec toutes
les tentatives
certes échoué mais tentative il ya eu de
renverser l'ordre constitutionnel du
pays on se souvient de ces
manifestations verte
il ya quelques années de cela deux ans
de ça navalni n'a jamais eu en tout cas
pour ses activités politiques
une condamnation réelle et forte
j'entends judiciaire parce que très
logiquement la russie estime que
objectivement et c'est vrai il ne
présente pas un danger réel politique et
c'est pas la peine d'en faire un pseudo
mandela 2-0 complètement montée en
épingle par l'occident mais là lorsque
la russie a gentiment laissé navalni
partir en allemagne alors que
normalement il devait juridiquement
reste en russie puisque ce oui encore un
sursis elle a en quelque sorte fait un
pas humanitaire et on va dire humain le
comportement de navalni derrière accusé
directement la russie à voir une espèce
de fixation qui devient pathologique
contre le président poutine
et la manière dont derrière la france et
l'allemagne ont utilisé cette affaire
navalni pour faire de la russie un
espèce de pays terroriste utilisant des
armes chimiques dans une rhétorique
passablement primaire est absolument pas
du tout justifiée argumenté c'est en
quelque sorte peut-être le pas de trop
ce qui explique aussi le comité
d'accueil des forces de l'ordre à qui
attendent la vanille en russie merci
beaucoup aux karine déchets biologiques
au professeur invité à l'université
d'état de moscou est on